all right so this girl is a popular
twitch streamer okay and this is one of
her moderators hi everyone look who's in
my house it's Dilly Dilly is living the
dream aren't you so happy to be here
yeah it's my dream y'all hi sopie hi bb
cat hi Omega hi Brandon hi lame hi Zeke
hello Ultra hello co I hate this I I oh
my days I already hate this why do I
hate this is it the tone dly wants to go
to the clubs so now I'm going to the
club too I'm only going so I can wingman
for him and help him talk to abgs he
said abg's he said ABG I think it's like
Asian bad girls something like
that cute couple baby are not dating I
did not claim this sorry that's so mean
but I'm don't claim it she's talking
about
him oh you [__] what oh you bit oh
you're such a good girl no I don't claim
this yo up this okay you know what let's
Okay okay maybe she meant this
relationship I made a donation goal $500
I will kiss Dilly so we hit it we hit it
but hopefully I will be drunk for that
let's take the first shot of the night
yeah is it too early no you meant this
okay you up you [__] up oh [__] you
are one Fed Up little you are using this
dude oh wow he's awkward you're not
awkward oh man
e yester dly got so drunk he was saying
can I say it on
stream what did you what what is it uh
how you have a 6 inch and you last 30
minutes you're flexing to the whole room
I mean I also do I the kind of drunk I
am I don't shut the up no you don't shut
the [__] up sober thank you so we did I
did a little thing last time where I
said for every 10 get I'll spank Dilly I
guess at the Red Demon now thank you for
reminding me get the bend over come here
just like go like that like this oh you
want sorry guys one second do I use my
hand I guess so ignore my bony ass legs
I just go like that bend over more what
the [__] is that my implant is like
[__] shaking from how hard my heart
is racing right now okay so before we do
this can you please clean yourself up
I'm going to clean up like make sure
there's no snot maybe rinse out your
mouth a little bit yeah oh my God okay
um well okay see you soon [__] literally
[__] all this is te oh [__] [__] fu fu
[__] oh my God I'm so so I'm so
nobody put a gun in your head you dumb
and on top of that it's your idea you
put it there you know damn know what the
[__] you
[Music]
doing you did
that one more
sh Dam if you ever want to get drunk
really fast just have to kiss still
you'll be [__] up by then the night's
over all right come on okay
okay
sorry wash my
mou Jesus
Christ so moist critical saw this video
and much like the internet everyone kind
of lost it I came and visited and I'm on
vacation right mhm and I was like hey
let's do some streams together right so
I know how to cook and I know she's into
cooking streams and then that we would
do like a drinking stream right so can
this guy have a name has name can this
guy have a [__] name his name is
Dilly no his name is [__] uh Su
Caitlyn's mob can this guy have a
[__] name put his put his name at
least but like we're talking to this
sub Caitlyn no no we're we're talking to
sub Caitlyn's mod that's just kind of
what happened I was like oh let's make
the most out of my trip because it was
like super last minute and she was like
super accommodating for a last minute
idea now when you I think all that
content idea sounds super logical but
did you discuss like you being the
subject of all of the jokes I I'm using
that word real Loosey Goosey here cuz in
in my opinion it's less jokes and more
just deep cut insults and I know you're
at her house right now so it might be a
little uncomfortable to get serious
about it but he's at her place while
he's doing this it felt more like she
used you to just insult perpetually to
bring you down to put up this I don't
want to use the word facade cuz I don't
know her but to put up this whole
barrier like this guy doesn't have a
chance let's laugh at him and that's
just that's not good like that's no one
deserves that kind of treatment right
and I I'm going tell you how
it's like it's a formula right this is
what it boils down to in her personality
right so the reason why I agreed to do
some of the things we that happened is
because the person I separate the person
from the streamer the content creator
from the person I friends with the
person and whatever it is like for
example right it could have been a super
hot guy and he could have had some kind
of ick like play I don't know rocket
League or he plays League of Legends but
he's like amazing everything she like e
you play League of Legends like I don't
know if this will work uh or you know
just like make witty comments about
something she might not like just
because it's contrary it is you know
cont not controversial but it can be
it's opposing right so for for it could
have been any it could have been
anybody couldn't be me and my friend
could never do that to me and I could
never do that to my friend this idea
that the content creator somehow super
separated from the person listen they
may not be identical but they're very
much linked how I am online is not
necessarily reflection of the totality
of who I am but it is part of me it's
why online I don't engage in behavior
that I think would be incredibly
Unbecoming to me that that's just a cop
out for responsibility for what the [__]
you say and the impact it has on people
and honestly it really doesn't change
much if my friend is getting online and
insulting me in all kinds of ways even
though they say yo it's just content
that [__] don't sit right with me why do
you got to turn our relationship into
content why are you so desperate for
money that you would disparage me to the
public like that that's weird that
reflects on your character anybody who
treats their friends like that it
reflects on them too it's one thing to
roast each other playfully whatever when
you're just out here making this person
seem like a [__] dork and you
constantly talk about how disgusting and
revolting they are one you're doing that
because you think it reflects the
reality to some degree that's why it's
funny cuz it's partially true she
wouldn't look at a Chad and have those
same jokes why because nobody would
believe it to be true but folks look at
you Dilly and think you know what what
she's saying people probably think in
real life this is entertaining it's a
humiliation experience and she can
humiliate you because you by societal
standards have a lot of qualities that
people would find not desirable and
you're letting your friend highlight
that bro I wouldn't even do that to my
enemies you're letting your friend do
that that's Twisted it's not the first
time she's kissed somebody on stream
right or like do content and it's
controversial so it just happened to be
my turn I have to set my feelings
aside and just understand if I'm going
to do content that that is what it
strictly is it doesn't H but it doesn't
have to be that way why did you even
have to say I have to put aside my
feelings What
feelings What feelings if this is
meaningless it doesn't matter what what
are the feelings that you have to put
aside it's just content right it's not
it's not it's not and if she was dealing
with someone she actually respected and
cared for she would never think of doing
that content with them why because it's
not just content she can do that to you
cuz a you're Expendable two she thinks
you're beneath her and three you think
you're beneath her and four it makes her
money those are the qualities that are
necessary for this to be real there's a
lot of thing that are content that you
could do to get ahead but they don't
reflect well on you I could sit up here
and have a stream with my mom and call
her all kinds of names in front of the
camera you get it'll go viral it'll go
super viral mhm but is that the kind of
content I would actually want to make do
I want to do it at the expense of my
mother do I want her to suffer the
humiliation of everybody messaging her
about it in real life like yeah you can
make content about anything doesn't mean
you should and doesn't mean it's just oh
it's just content we're just creators no
the kind of [__] you like to create has
a reflection on it I went through and
watched how she interacts with other
friends of hers in the space like Hassan
and everyone like that why doesn't she
treat them the same way she treated you
what what's the deal with that then how
come she's able to do other content with
other guys that aren't her perpetually
insulting them the entire time but you
the only content she does with you is to
make you the punching bag why okay so I
mean for I mean like she's not like for
his Sonic example right she went over
and just kind of say the reality was
like we just did a stream together he
was a nice guy you're nice guy yeah but
but she was also honestly like I'm not
super into that kind of content of
political right but I appreciate she
appreciated the offer right so she will
be real and say separate herself for a
moment and just say this is what
happened yada y y right hey my my dude
you OD in on the cope it's like you work
for a government right now yep you work
for the government the way you dodge
these answers and you dodge the
questions by not answering what you're
supposed to to
answer question was very simple why is
she able to do content with other dudes
not insulting them like she did you well
the thing
is I was going to to but then I filled
them do you understand so fent and I'm
made it here today thank you did you say
fat asian whoa Mas that's what I heard
Mas play the agent Empires
huh cool that's what I heard okay so
like I was sh Pon that's it James Brown
is my favorite
artist this is not like I don't know
it's just it's it's hard to kind of like
you know just like when you're on
someone's team right and you don't want
to to mess up that Dynamic right you're
understanding that we're all playing
Parts on a team right and yeah my role
on that team is kind of [__] up but
some people are built that kind of way
to be like put that stress on my
shoulders and just like you know because
they care about people that's my role
I'm a
doormat and my job as a doormat is for
people to
just lay they dirty [__] on
me and it sounds like we're being harsh
but like you need to hear this and
there's going to come a time when you
realize this you're going to be rid of
her or she's going to be rid of you and
you're going to look back at this moment
like how was I so pathetic and I hope
from that point you start to build up
your self-esteem properly because
anybody who views themselves being worth
anything and I know people with $ Z in
the bank account who are homeless who
would never tolerate the kind of [__]
you're tolerating right now okay that's
a self-esteem issue but that is your
responsibility to fix here not for you
to come online and run defense for the
person who's harming you now she is a
different kind of piece of [__] she will
use people with no regard for how it
makes them feel on the inside for their
reputation like here's the thing even if
my friend gave me consent even if my
friend says I can't wait to do this even
my friend said anything I'm like bro
it's not right it ain't even about you
what does it say about me that I would
take advantage of you like that but
you're not taking advantage yes I am yes
I am this not right and if you can't see
that as a person you still treat it like
oh it's just content is because yo you
engage in trash behaviors that's it you
can do this to him but not Hassan
because the truth is you would never try
to do this with somebody who's you see
is above you that's it it's not about
friends and none [__] like preach said
you a doormat well you're a doormat of
the company and you should you should
carry the logo of that company people
are still going to drop their [__] on
you you're still a doormat doormat do
you think she cares about you yeah
genuinely like when I went through my
breakup she uh set me up on to have a
dating show like that's using you for
content again
though
bro there's a sunken
place I was ready you know to hear like
oh maybe she gave him a call and she
talked him through and she was most she
supported okay that's support she turn
his misery into content as if someone
who's freshly broken up needs to go on
some stupid [__] twitch dating show
that leads nowhere and other people can
just laugh at how pathetic you are and
you get rejected again and again hey yo
when she is saying these things to your
face when she is saying you are not
good-looking you're not getting laid I
will never hit I don't claim this all of
those things does it make you
happy I mean obviously it's not going to
make anybody happy if you hear that kind
of stuff right but at the same time you
know it's just like if you're real with
yourself and you understand where you
are or where I am I understand where I
am at right now in my life and like
where I want things to go it's just you
I have to set my emotions aside when I
hear things like that and that's I'm
just been used to that kind of stuff
that's just no you've just been used
yeah you're a doormat and um there's
never a time with any of my friends that
they have to set aside their emotions on
a regular
basis with me to to make me feel better
and if they do that's a really
unbalanced unhealthy relationship your
friends should come to you and feel a
place of comfort not a place where
they're going to be put down and have to
set aside their emotions or how they
feel about everything that you're saying
that's a weird dynamic think about your
friends would you guys like that if they
constantly say foul things to you and
you have to set that aside and just take
it on the chin I used to see Dynamics
like that in school all the time where
one kid used to get ragged on by a group
of people and he's like well they let me
sit with them at lunch yeah but they
take your lunch money and they call you
a d in front of everybody else and later
on these people are never friends they
don't stick around each other no they
always separate this is exactly that
that's what this is and I feel like
twitch often times is for a lot of
people who have stunted growth socially
speaking like these are people in their
late 20s are still social retards so
they can say stuff like this but it's
frightening that we're seeing High
School behavior in people's late 20s and
people are making profit out of that
thing in high school is we're growing
we're being stupid and we're doing that
not it's High School Behavior but
someone is taking advantage of you
monetarily that's crazy yep what kind of
[__] I decide to deal with right and
just on the you know like what's the
difference from like you know like I
guess the difference of like um for like
content right like me and you right I'm
trying to put that out there that hey
I'm a grown man I just I I take
responsibility for you know
understanding what I was going to sign
up for right so we're both playing two
sides of the coin here right now right
we're both getting there's content from
one side and you're getting content from
this as well well it's very different
though like but we keep talking about
content again at the very beginning your
the content you pitched is different
than the content that came out you
pitched doing cooking or drinking all
that the that wasn't the content the
content was her making fun of you that
doesn't sound like what you wanted to do
I don't think you told her I want you to
insult the [__] out of me for over an
hour like that's that's not the content
that I think you wanted to sign up for I
think that is the content that was
sprung upon you and you feel as though
you have to take it because you keep
saying that it's your decision you can
bear the burden you're an adult you can
make your own decisions which of course
you can but why you just said it doesn't
make you happy when she says those
things so what's the point you don't
need that to have a career and I don't
think you should want that to be your
legacy or career either like being
Caitlyn's punching bag I've been suppos
to be a doctor so that's why I don't you
know have that as like the craziest
thing on my mind right now but um you
know I I wanted to talk to people and
just understand that when you know when
you have a love and and that's prob
that's just me in my [__] up ways
right saying the content she does is
entertaining enough for me to support it
and be a part of a cast of people that
agree and that that there's some
benefits this guy's taking a really long
route to say I'm quasi in love with this
girl and what she does and I'm willing
to be her punching bag as a result this
is unrequited love this is part of that
friend group where they're mean to you
and you accepted cuz you just want to be
seen with them and cuz you don't know
your worth the closest that you're going
to be to whatever the [__] you want to
be with her is a punching bag yep and
you accept to be the punching B because
that's the closest of whatever you could
be y it's the closest to a real
friendship or whatever the [__] it is in
your head that you want to be to her the
punching bag is the best option this is
like just the more extreme version of
the friend zone where people accept a
set of circumstances they do not want to
be in just to be able to be close to the
person they really want to be with
congratulations I say it's the friend
zone because if one person or the one
who's like who made the terms for friend
zone says I want to be in a relationship
with you they're immediately going to
band friendship that's not a friendship
you are just another Suitor in Waiting
hoping for a shot that's what you are
you've left your resume at the door and
you're calling and calling and calling
you know you're just like hey is there
do you guys want some coffee whatever
that's what you're doing that's it it's
pathetic and for anyone watching I hope
that you guys never tolerate these kind
of circumstances your personal life be
it friendships be it whatever the [__]
it is you should never ever tolerate
being a doormat for someone else's
well-being or their financial gain or
their emo nothing and also for you guys
watching you should never be the
perpetrator of this Behavior don't keep
these people in the friend zone do not
keep these people on a leash for your
own monetary gain for your own punching
bag oh friends whatever it is do never
do that because it reflects poorly on
you too that's what I'll say
congratulations ABA you just created the
punch Zone anything else nope let us
know what you guys think